[Music]
all right
so
nowadays nowadays especially like
friends and stuff
we just see a plethora of islamophobia
actually i even saw this one girl on
tick tock
that was she was trying to make a point
you know the whole um
what's it called uh would you let your
son wear a dress conversation that's
going on
i had no idea about that what okay so i
think it started with harry styles
wearing a dress
you guys you guys don't know about that
that's that's a dude that um
wasn't he from one direction yeah one
direction yeah you guys are out of touch
yeah
yeah so he put on a address and i think
because of that everybody started asking
everyone like would you let your son
wear a dress and people were giving
their input and this and that
and this one christian tick talker she
was like um
saying a bunch of things she tried to
make a point like when kids tell their
parent or what sorry when parents tell
the kids what to do
no one says anything when muslim
she basically said when muslim parents
force their daughters to wear the hijab
nobody says anything but when we say we
wouldn't as christians when we say we
wouldn't let our sons wear dresses you
get angry and it's like
why the hell you gotta bring islam into
it and why you gotta depict it in such
like a westernized tv show slash movie
version like i've never seen a tv show
or movie that has a hijabi
where she doesn't like rip it off one
episode
or get get it torn off or something like
yeah why where is this coming from yo
you know what i didn't i didn't really
think it was that big until you mention
it but
it really seems like there's this like
deeply rooted like
agenda against us
and it's not even like it's not even
subtle anymore man like i watch these
shows and like
i'm just living life you know and it's
very overt
i don't like that but yeah i feel like i
don't know a lot
of people won't understand why it is
like that like for me
initially i didn't understand why it was
like that
yeah i mean if we're using the whole red
pill blue pill analogy thing again it's
kind of like
you know everybody's blue pill they're
just living life and they think
everything's normal
and it's kind of like being best friends
with someone like if you guys ever know
othello
do you guys read that by shakespeare no
no okay so basically there's this guy
um and this is around the time when the
uh the term cucked i think
came around so
um there's this guy and there's two guys
right
one is his his name is iago i think and
he's like an evil person he pretends to
be
the guy's friend the entire time but
he's just slowly manipulating him and
ruining his life over time and it's kind
of like living in this society
it's like the it's like the way it's
structured is iago right
the way you're living your life you
think everything's normal
but it's actually it's this whole plan
in the background that's been
just been put in place and over time
it's just been
conducted and executed and it's kind of
like we think it's normal
but if you were to take that red pill
step outside and look at
the bigger picture you'd see wait no
there's some weird trends going on here
like you could see if you read the
history like nowadays we wear poppies
and my teacher was
talking about this in class he says like
now like we wear poppies nowadays and he
said that he never
wears his poppy and back when he worked
uh i think at a pharmacy
his co-workers asked him like why don't
you wear a poppy and he said i don't
support terrorism
and everyone's like what the hell are
you talking about and he's like yeah
yeah
canada and and all these places when
they went and they they
went into muslim lands and they they
basically ended the ottoman empire
they murdered innocent people they raped
innocent people they did all this stuff
i don't support that so i'm never gonna
wear a poppy and it's kind of like
people don't know about the history ever
since i was a kid they
they taught us to put this cute little
red thing it looks nice
on like a black coat and all this stuff
that's what my teacher was saying
um but they never really talk about who
this big bad enemy was
that canada saved us from this
apparently was the ottoman empire it was
amongst the people fighting we're in the
muslims
and this was the last islamic leadership
the proper islamic leadership that we
had
and it's like nobody even knows about
this so it started there
actually started before that with
implementing western ideology into the
ottoman empire
and then just from there you can
literally look up and listen to and read
about how
the west drew up the map of the middle
east and they said this is going to be
jordan this is iraq this is lebanon this
is
they literally drew it up pause this the
same ottoman empire that i think they
they converted that big i think it was
like the hagar sofia church or something
in turkey and they convert it into a
mosque
it's the same one so bro i don't speak
on behalf of i know
i'ma speak on behalf of me i have no
idea about
any of this so i think you should go in
on this
who me or angel you bro oh
i mean i don't know man i know if you
want to go in on the ottoman empire and
the whole revolution
go for it man i have no idea me neither
bro
i do have a question about it but i'll
ask you i don't know i don't know much
about
yeah i don't know much about like the
church becoming a mosque and all that
stuff
no man that was those i do know about
some of the places the ottomans spread
to
it was the biggest church in uh
in turkey and they they
changed it into a mosque yeah bro
it's kind of tough it's kind of mean to
be honest
taking the church like that it is man i
don't know what that to be honest
it's had a lot i don't even know if
that's islamically correct but we had
some good leaders some bad leaders
i'll look into that inshallah later on
but yeah moving back to
what i was getting at there is this
small implementation of like western
views by muslim scholars
that studied in places like france and
they were
injecting them into the muslim community
so they had this internal battle
so anything external that comes in
they're not really ready for it and this
is when like everything's hard to go to
hell
world war one ruined them and then the
west drew up the map of the middle east
divide and conquer basically it's like
if they're divided amongst themselves
they can't come together and be
because they know how strong the muslims
are they know literally one of the
longest lasting empires
and the greatest empire muslim the the
ottoman empire since
the time of the foster they said
down the line like a thousand plus years
a thousand years subhanallah being the
greatest power in the world
it was the muslims people don't know
about that they want to hide that kind
of information
they want to hide that science and
mathematics and and all these amazing
advancements
universities hospitals they came from
the muslims subhanallah
people don't know about that stuff they
don't know about that when you wake up
and brush your teeth in the morning
the toothbrush was designed by a muslim
originally
yeah bro no that's facts bro like
you you ever seen like you ever seen
queen elizabeth's teeth bro
i'm not talking about like when you're
seeing like paintings or pictures like
where where it's like after you know
getting it done or you know
reconstructed i'm talking about it
before bro they didn't brush their teeth
oral hygiene was literally commanded to
us
as sunnah i believe because it's
literally the way to preserve our teeth
through our life
we use uh or back then they didn't
really have toothbrushes so they used
this thing called the miswak
yeah all right bro come on now
of a tree yeah it's a branch of a tree
that you break off and then you kind of
bite the tip
and then uh you you soften it and it
becomes like these bristles
on the end of it and you just like with
the bristles of it like a bristles of a
toothbrush basically
hold on but you you bite you bite the
tip
shut the hell up
[Laughter]
yo that's crazy man that's crazy that uh
islam is on the whole hygiene thing like
that because
recently dude i actually found out that
i had uh
gingivitis for a long time like did do
y'alls
do y'alls gums bleed when you brush your
teeth every
now and then or like random what happens
when you don't floss
yeah bro i've never flossed a day in my
life and then like
i started having uh one of the gums on
like my tooth started to like recede and
i was like yo what is this like what is
going on here and then i
come to find out i had to floss and then
sloshing but
it's crazy that islam was on that whole
game
yeah man um if it wasn't obvious enough
we got to kind of wash our hands
rinse our mouths wash our face run our
hands through our hair
arms all that five times a day man
all our prayers man it's uh that's
that's what we do
is all about man it's just cleansing our
body yeah we do
so it's it's actually like like it's
obligatory for us to do it five times a
day
before it eats daily prayer but it's
sunnah to do it 15 times a day
so three times per um obviously that's
why you do it three times when you do
because that's something that's what the
prophet did but it's obligatory to do it
once
yeah man so bro when coleman came and
they were like yo you got to like spend
time washing your hands
you got to do this you got to do that
you got to go in it's almost second
nature
and muslims were already on that yeah
yeah we're proud about it
yeah so i mean like okay yeah
a thousand years ago or not a thousand
years ago sorry um a few hundred years
ago ottoman empire this that the other
yeah right
um what does that do with today but um
what people don't know is that knowing
where it started
is probably the most important part
right you know how we say
um the biggest problem a person can have
is not knowing they have a problem
they didn't know they had a problem
until it was kind of like you know
like ko they're done um
subhanallah so like yeah started then
and then it moved over time and francis
had a problem for a long time
but now in the west in the west
i'm just going to name a couple of
things that islam prohibits right
alcohol smoking in talks against drugs
unless it's pharmaceutical and like for
medical purposes
what about the stereotype about the
arabs at uh
shisha bars that's nowhere
i challenge anyone to bring me one
hadith or one uh quran verse that that
shows we're allowed to go to shisha bars
so that's all culture 100
100 i had i had so many arabs growing up
habibi you know we can't smoke weed we
can't smoke you know no kush we're not
balling up but
we'll go ham on that on that shisha on
the hookah
you want to hit it i'm like oh isn't it
yeah yeah it always seemed like a
contradiction but it's good to know that
you're bringing it up as it's not really
like founded on anything
yeah it's not a lot of like people think
it's enough that it came from arab
arabic people now it's a muslim thing
it's not a muslim thing
anything that's damaging to your health
is is prohibited because your health is
a priority in islam your body is a right
that you have been given
and it's a responsibility something you
have to take care of so if you're
smoking and damaging your body you will
be held accountable for that and it's
haram because you're
harming yourself we're taught not to
harm ourselves or others
so smoking and shisha they talk about
the doctors talk about just how bad it
is
so oh cigarettes man hundred percent
worse
an hour of just you know out of shisha
bar
just taking puffs and taking hits bro
it's like the equivalent of i think 30
cigarettes
oh my god that's insane that's nasty
um and it's just they got all these
flavors like mango flavor
citrusy flavor they got all these you
know and
yeah subhanallah um so yeah that's
that's not in islam either so
what else what else uh what would you
say is prohibited
in terms of smoking in terms of smoking
um
i would say what are your thoughts on
like
vape pens and stuff like that because
yeah people are gonna be like hey man
there's no drugs
yeah i was gonna say this is this
depends on the situation of a person so
if a person was smoking
and now they want to switch from
cigarettes to a vape pen
in order to help them get rid of their
habit so they can
maybe smoke less and less or do
something that's a little less damaging
then in that case i believe some
scholars say it's okay
because you're trying to quit smoking
right
so in that sense it's all right but um
if you're just
buying a pen just to vape or just to
smoke
this can also be damaging as well
it could be depending depending um a lot
of a lot of people add nicotine
which is an addictive substance i
believe
and other things as well so it really
depends but i believe
all of them are haram at the end of the
day i don't think any of them are really
healthy
um i think all of them fall into the
unhealthy category so it's better to
avoid it
but obviously go to the professionals on
that matter
so i would include that in smoking as
well so music
smoking pornography including like
nightclubs and
and all these provocative things um
interest is haram damn
uh what else i know i know i got i got
something to say about that
all right so yeah music pornography
gambling as well i lost count i forgot
how many i'm counting
gambling all these things right what you
what you what you notice when i
say this is why i notice when i when i
read that list though is
these are big money makers these are big
industries pornography huge industry
music is a huge industry
cigarettes and alcohol they're huge
especially when it comes to the
governments because they
they take a percentage of that same
thing
yeah same thing with gambling huge money
maker huge
money loser for the people who are
gambling a lot of the time
and uh the government does take money
from that as well
so it's kind of like if everyone was a
perfect muslim nobody
would be doing these things and these
businesses would lose their money
do you not think people would want that
religion to go away mm-hmm
100 man that that that really brings me
to the question i was gonna ask angel
bro you're a new reaper have you ever
wondered why
islam just demonized in the west or have
you not
have you not felt that growing up tell
me about your experience growing up did
you feel like there was always this like
subtle propaganda sometimes not so
subtle just
making you sway away from islam or even
wanting to like learn about it
dude every time that i talked about it
with someone
it was always like the whole idea of
terrorists
and just the stuff that we see in the
media
that was all that came up anytime that
islam
was a uh a part of the conversation
it's sad bro it's sad to say that yeah
it's it's deep man like it really goes
deep so
the thing with the west right is
you have a pretty much you have a
capitalist economy right
which runs on credit and the thing with
that is
islam completely prohibits that bro like
islam we call it
right as rami was talking about reba is
interest or usury so this is not okay in
islam this is not condoned for in islam
at all whatsoever
so in the west we have this capitalist
economy that runs on credit
and there's a few select people at the
top that
own almost all the wealth and majority
which is 99.9 of the wealth owned 0.01
percent of the wealth
of the total wealth in the accumulating
in the west
so this immense power hierarchy and uh i
guess
deviants between the people at the top
and most of the average people like us
you and i and rami um this has led to
this control right this this system
that's been in place since time
the same values the same way things have
been going in america
america can no longer be america if all
of these things are now
prohibited so what can they do they
can't just out overtly i guess
tell people this is wrong um don't
listen to islam
because here's the thing you can't deny
the truth bro when islam starts coming
to you
it's gonna resonate with you it is the
ultimate truth so people aren't gonna
shy away from that but what they can do
is they can demonize
it they can make it out to be something
that's you know scary or violent or
whatever
you know you were talking about was in
the media
and what this is gonna do is it's gonna
stop people from studying it and if
you're demonized from it you don't study
it you're not gonna know about it
most people are just gonna live life
coasting through being atheist or
agnostic
or christian but not really practicing
you know what i mean
so this is a very surefire easy way to
prevent people from
knowing the truth because this whole
capitalist economy won't survive
even muslim countries are now getting
corrupt guys like saudi arabia didn't
have
taxes for the longest time and now as
you can see
there i think they just recently started
implementing taxes or they will start
what islam says though is we need to
have uh
uh you know donating 2.5 roughly
of our annual earnings to charity
so islam says that if everyone did that
in the world and they donated just 2.5
of their earnings
guys that's 1 000 if you earn 40 000
which is the average income that's
that's nothing
this would be enough sufficiently to end
world poverty
but here's the thing we have people like
the average joe's here
earning 20 30 000 a year and they're
paying 20 25
in income taxes and you got people
earning millions and billions
which are weaseling their way out from
not paying taxes at all
so you tell me man what's better
shahanallah
i'm just like mind blown right now like
i'm just i'm processing all this
um i actually got a question before we
even continue on this it's completely
off this topic kind of referring back to
the ottoman empire
but just like just something that i had
in mind because i was looking into it
the other day
and you know how in islam uh they have
the
the moon with the star
yeah so like is that would that
really be considered the symbol of islam
no by no means if that was just the uh
the symbol that was uh
forgot but like before the ottoman
empire became the thing uh
they had taken over this one city and
that was their symbol and like that
symbol
basically was worshiping like the moon
goddess or something like that
romney is he talking about the the
symbol on the turkish flag
i think so i think so so um yeah islam
doesn't have any simple even today it
doesn't have any symbol
this uh crescent moon thing was brought
about i believe in the 19th century by
the ottoman empire
but you'll never find the quran or the
sunnah or anything
saying that this is the symbol of islam
so i mean it doesn't have anything to do
with islam if a person comes on later on
and kind of tries to make it the symbol
of islam it doesn't really change the
religion it didn't come from the prophet
salallahu
they came from people afterwards i've
heard these kind of arguments before
um but it falls apart because it's never
it was never meant to be the symbol of
islam
from the time the falsehood sent them
and after that it's just it was
implemented by
people like almost a thousand years
later okay why why is it on like
mosques um that's a good question
honestly i don't know why they adopted
that i really don't know i mean don't
get me wrong it's it's a nice symbol
like
i like the crescent moon it's beautiful
but it's just like after looking into it
it's kind of like
you know what i mean yeah i mean we do
use a lunar calendar though
right like we use the moon to determine
like when it's ramadan
and all that stuff so we use lunar
calendar um
we also use it in the sense of like okay
it's magruder or sasha and all of that
as well
the time of day if you don't have like
clocks in like the advan app or
something
um so it is obviously the moon is
significant to all matters that
we we deal with in life our existence as
well
but we do use it as a tool as a
mechanism in islam but um
yeah a lot of people like to use this
like moon god kind of thing
um but again i don't really think
there's much of a basis to that
yo are you beginning to to see
how and why islam is manifested as
something demonic
and to be demonized to keep people away
and it really helps the west flourish in
the way that it's been flourishing in
right according to its own standards so
it keeps the society going
keeps that credit keeps people in debt
keeps people in control
in check right there's a lot of things
that
you know we haven't talked about so far
um and it just gets people confused and
always in a state of
dysphoria and stress and just
apathy man and they they just don't know
what's what and it's really easy to
control people like that
all those things romney talked about
drugs pornography
alcohol man these these are
multi-trillion dollar industries
combined like these really do make money
and at the end of the day
a capitalist economy can't run without
money right so
you kind of need these things and you
kind of have to make this narrative
oh man it's okay like you don't need to
worry about consequences just
just come home from work you know pour
that glass of wine or like just roll
that
roll that blunt take your stress away
you know
islam is demonized while simultaneously
promoting and propagating these things
in a very subtle way
what do you have hip-hop music let's
talk about that so
this whole culture right of music
all it does is and i'm just gonna be
honest with you like i don't smoke
you know y'all don't smoke but you
listen to these songs and you know it's
it's it's bumping and it has a beat and
it just makes you want to just roll up a
blunt
it's like why like why why is all rap
about
you know drugs women and all that
you got you got alcohol you got gambling
why is it so easily accessible man
so in canada we have this this thing
called the lcbo you know you don't know
about that
but rami knows about that so you know
over here
alcohol is really extremely regulated
compared to the states right
so you can only buy it at these liquor
stores not like a 711 or a gas station
especially being underage man i've seen
people do that in the states it's crazy
but anyway over here what we do is lcbo
it has specific hours of operation right
so you can buy alcohol out of that
and i think you can buy like wine and
little stuff like that in the grocery
stores
but even then there's like hours to do
that so
throughout the pandemic when kova 19 hit
and we went under lockdown
bro the gyms closed down the gym i work
at closed down too
for a bit what's crazy though is the
lcbos never went out
of business you got people that
would use working out as a coping
mechanism against mental dysfunction
now having to cope with a bottle because
they can't even go to the gym anymore
so it's like the people in power don't
really have their priorities in check at
all
rami's right at the end of the day all
these things that
are promoted today um it's just to get
people weak
more i i was about to say they they
definitely got their priorities in check
but
it's their priorities their agenda not
our priorities
so at the end of the day like you say
their property is not ours
and a lot of people might hear that and
be like okay why are your priorities
even correct
who are you guys to set the gold
standard the objective truth
rami what do you think about all these
things that we talked about so far yeah
i i wouldn't even use the um the term
our interest or our well what was the
term used
our priorities or our priorities yeah
yeah i would use our best interest right
and it's everybody's best interest
because
alcohol is damaging cigarettes is
damaging pornography is damaging
music will sway you in a way it'll
influence you in a way and if it's not
proper
then it will impact you negatively so
all these things are damaging
so it's not just our priorities as
muslims
it's actually everybody's best interest
to cut out these things
to live the best physical and and
emotionally
mentally healthy life they can live and
this is why
or these are some of the reasons we can
derive um from
allah or god making certain things haram
why do you think you know being
promiscuous is haram because it leads to
so many more evils
it leads to so many more evils and you
see that pornography started as
something that's like
straight then it went to homosexuality
then it went to
really really really really weird things
really weird things
and even illegal things now and it's
kind of like
what do you think like what do you think
these problems come from
a couple years ago i'd be like yo what
are you talking about uh promiscuity
leads to evil
man look at all these kids growing up
with our fathers and without parents
no one's taking accountability for
anything you're filming
at the end of the day like in islam we
have this thing called the
the neka right a lot of people don't
know about that but
um for anyone that's wondering and
especially like angel
you're new to islam so i just want to
get this clear right now islam
really doesn't have a problem with
physical intimacy at all bro
it does a matter of fact it encourages
it but in the right way
so we have this thing called the nikah
which is like this public i guess
witnessing or this this is just this
official
marriage right not some marriage and
like some like state marriage or like
some like legal thing
where you know the state has a fair uh
has a say in your household not
a nikah literally could be done in 10
minutes
doesn't even have to be done at a mosque
you know contrary to people's prior
preconceived notions
could be as as cheap as five dollars and
here's how it works bro
and nika is literally having two
witnesses
right to just see that you and a chick
are now unionized
once that's done y'all can do whatever
bro yeah there's a little more nuances
that you know maybe we'll talk about in
another call
about like the maher which is the dowry
that the man gives to the woman and the
wali which is a male guardian of the
woman
and all that we could talk about that
but in essence in summation
is just a unionization of two people and
it's done in public with witnesses
here's why remember how rami was talking
about oh promiscuity is the same and all
that
yeah because of the application and
implication that i brought up
people are growing up today without
paternity people are growing up without
a father nobody knows
don't you see like it could lead to a
lot of problems if the
nikkei wasn't there islam made the
nikkei um
obligatory because at the end of the day
inheritance couldn't be a thing without
the nikkei
all right you got kids going up like oh
i should be the one in hearing
when they're not even biologically
related bro to the to the person that
passed away
and you also got people that are
biologically related
not getting the money right so that's a
problem
you got people like back then like
obviously
i don't think anyone watching this will
support cheating and
you know extramarital affairs and all
that
but here's the thing adultery can't be a
thing if people don't know
that you're with someone else right if
rami has a wife and no one knows about
that
is it really cheating if he gets with
another girl
no but you have the two witnesses you
have the imam seeing that rami got
uh a neca with a woman so now they're
one
so if rami's ever seen with another girl
they already know what his business is
what his deal is they already know this
guy already had
uh a neca a unionization a contract with
a woman
so it can't be even seen as cheating
romney not to throw you under the bus
bro
um but ladies he is single so if you
want to be that that woman for the
unionization
this is what it is yes yes rami is
singing i mean
i mean i have four slots open your four
slots open what if what if they see me
with like my second wife or something
what if they see me with like my second
wife
uh here's the thing they already know
that the second wife had an account with
you
right okay before before a lot of people
a lot of people might be like oh guys
why are you allowed to have four wives
like at the end of the day guys monogamy
and take it as you will you guys don't
have to agree with everything i'm saying
but
monogamy is not natural when you look at
nature
polygamy is the norm bro and even today
you got you got guys having you know
their main chick you got guys having
their
side chick then you got something else
on the side then you got whatever
new you know comes into the picture that
you don't really respect but you're just
gonna you know get with it's like
bro men are gonna be poligenous anyway
but in the west it's okay when it's
cheating and it's haram and it's
it's in the open but y'all wouldn't
really have it officiated see
it's not you're allowed to have four
wives it's you gotta be a man that's
held accountable and can handle four
wives you gotta have income that can
support
all of them you gotta make sure you're
giving all of them equal financial
treatment you gotta make sure each of
them
are cool with you having other wives you
got to make sure you could take care of
all the kids that you have
it's not just out here spreading your
seed with with people without taking
accountability like you see in the west
there's levels to this bro there's
levels of accountability there's levels
of professionalism
and at the end of the day i feel like
bro i don't know
too many people that have multiple wives
but the ones i do know
man their wives are really happy
contrary to people's beliefs
they're super like joyous whenever i see
them they always got a smile on their
face
not like these single moms in the 30s
just always with the frown on their face
you know
their kids are wonderful bro each of
them are probably earning like
the dads i'm talking about are probably
earning 500 to like 800k
plus per year so they're they're really
on their purpose
it's not it's not something where you
just hit it and quit it
and you know do that with multiple women
and man
get that out the window yeah just add on
to that
yeah go ahead go ahead just to add on to
that i want to mention
um this is what i love about islam
because it's
it's it has something for like every
time every place
and i would say any society because if
you have a
monogamous society you're allowed to
marry only one allah actually
puts the words in the quran marry just
one but that's if you're incapable
of being married to multiple if taking
care of them so if you live in a
society where financially most people
can't then you're obli you're obligated
to marry just one and that's
in the quran you can like me right now
if i can even marry one at this point
if i can even marry one it's only one
it's only one
and i'm obligated i'm not allowed me i'm
speaking right now
to the audience to everybody to youtube
me as a man i'm not allowed to have two
three four wives islamically speaking
i'm not allowed to i like i know i
thought uh on my tick tock live all the
time i have four thoughts out four slots
i'm not allowed to it's not it's not
feasible in the west it's not
logically coherent to do that in this
kind of society
and a lot of women are against it
because they've been brought up on this
monogamous
um platform i would say yeah with the
idea that that's monogamy
yeah no no go on with the idea that
monogamy is the one and only way and
having
a second where you're having your men
having a second wife not girlfriend not
mistress not cheating
a second wife is horrible when that
happens if that happens to them they're
gonna experience the cognitive
dissonance like we talked about
they're gonna think i was brought up
like this but i'm experiencing this and
it's gonna cause them
to feel anxious and depressed and this
is something that a lot of us
a lot of us have to take in it's not
logically coherent in the west but
if a woman is okay with it and you are
capable of doing it it is halal
go for it bro here's the thing here's
what i always tell people
your woman your wife at the end of the
day you should be telling her as it is
bro
you shouldn't be creating this false
narrative to keep her
right because because you feel like the
truth would would get her to have other
views of you
and you shouldn't be changing who you
are bro to appease a girl
that's that's not that's not what we're
doing around here we're trying to be who
we
are and if the chick is okay with that
cool alhamdulillah if she's not it is
what it is bro
imagine this bro from my experience
girls always change their lives and
and revolve their whole lives around the
guy that they truly care about
not some guy that they just see as you
know sunday night not a guy that they
just see as you know
i don't really take him seriously he's
like my texting buddy or like my work
husband no i'm talking about
the man you feel me um a girl really
changes her life man for that guy and at
the end of the day
imagine a girl does that and then like
three years down the line she's like yo
what i didn't i you know everything was
a lie there's so much that you didn't
tell me about
you're not who you were you got three
whole households aside from me
what is this but combine that to compare
that to a guy that like
told her as it is before they even got
together it's real it's raw
she knew what it was when she signed up
there's no surprises there's no shock
and this whole thing about monogamy
you're bringing up bro you're right man
it's it's it's nowhere in
even catholicism bro like if you look at
i think it was abraham had four wives
and i think isaac had won
peace be upon both of them or abraham
had one and isaac had four
so it's it's not like it's some new age
thing in this song
it's been there bro but they they
created this indoctrination that oh
monogamy is a way i mean i'll
use a social construct i'm not saying
monogamy is bad
i'm not saying monogamy's not the way
i'm just saying in islam
we have polygeny which is one man with
multiple women
an option right but it has to be done
right there's specific nuances that must
be
met in the halal way not just something
we can just do because we feel like it
you know it's also sunnah to marry
ex-widows and divorcees because let's
imagine you're
a 30-something-year-old single mother
with kids
generally men wouldn't want to marry
someone in that situation
as their one and only wife me personally
i wouldn't want to i'd
rather and yes it's it's it's a
stereotype i'm being honest i'd rather
marry a younger
more beautiful girl who hasn't been
married before that doesn't have kids
100
responsibility honestly at that point
less responsibility
i would rather do that most men would
rather do that whether they admit it or
not whether they admit it or not
most men would rather do that so the
issue is with society
because if most men are not going to do
that you can't make them do that but if
you give them the option
then they can be similar to the prophet
salallahu who married mainly
mainly widowed women divorced women
so on and so forth women that have a
hard time getting married and
society like this it's so not to marry
an older woman
so when when people when people look at
the prophet and they're like oh is this
what islam is about
man the prophet you know i'm talking
about right now i know do you know about
the prophet
sallam's first wife
vaguely okay so her name was khadijah
um peace and blessings honor man she was
i think married to the prophet for how
many years rami
oh that's a good question um i believe
it was 20 something years if not
under 20 but over 10.
i think okay he got married when he was
25 he
became a prophet at 40 that's 15 years
and i think
under 10 years later she died so in
between 20
yeah between 15 and 20 something like
that something like that yeah
inshallah guys correct us if we're wrong
but
for the entire entirety of that marriage
between the prophet saws and his first
wife khadija peace and blessings behind
both of them
bro he was monogamous
people don't know about that not once
did he have another spouse not once did
he cheat
nothing like that bro and then after
you know when he had other spouses yeah
then he practiced collision but did it
right
a lot of people might also also ask like
okay what changed
why why why is it after uh sadija um
that you know he kind of went
politionist
and i tell you guys the same thing like
all the other prophets before uh
the prophet salallahu all of the ones
before that
also practice pulligen nothing changed
there was always an option
it's always it's always there there's
nothing wrong about that it's just we
if you guys think about it if if i ask
someone can you guys objectively
tell me either of you two one reason why
pelogeny is wrong
can you guys give me even one no
you just it just feels some type of way
and anything that feels some type of way
is either through years of conditioning
and programming through society
or you actually have some personal
agenda against it but
there can be subhan allah you know what
i'm thinking about now
this is not an islamic concept this is
not based in quran this is not based on
sunnah this is not from a scholar this
is something that just popped my head
now so don't take it
as an islamic thing but i'm thinking
like okay yeah so there were cases where
allah revealed to the prophet
that he should marry a specific woman
there were cases
right but now i'm thinking like i feel
like a lot of men
especially muslim men who begin to learn
about islam people like myself
who go through a heartbreak right there
at the beginning they're with somebody
with this idea of monogamy pure monogamy
i'm going to be with this person the
rest of my life i'm going to love them
they're going to be my queen this not
the other right they have that mentality
and then they get their heart broken
mainly because they chose the wrong girl
and because of that mentality
because they don't know what it's like
to be you know a man and to actually
keep a woman so they get their
heartbreak
and then they go down this like perhaps
red pill black pill back to red pill
kind of
road and then they become a little more
polygonous in the sense
that they they they question the
monogamy kind of
side of things like i i had right so i'm
just wondering
like the heart the heartbreak the
prophet
experienced when khadija radillahu
passed away do you think that kind of
opened up in his heart the idea of being
politicist because when you're with your
first love it's the first love right
you don't feel like you can love anybody
else right and then your heart gets
broken so love is never the same for you
so then you're okay with being with
multiple women because you can feel like
you can love them the same
because love is not that first
you know experience that you had anymore
it changed
for anyone that's like what is this red
pill thing he's talking about guys
this this whole red pill blue coat thing
originally from the matrix
all it means is when you take the blue
pill it's pretty much what society wants
you to believe
right it's this whole disney hollywood
fairy tale
romance narrative where you think oh
women are everything nice sugar and
spice or whatever they say and
they'll never cheat on you i'm not
saying all women are gonna cheat but but
hear me out
and it's just like oh they'll love you
unconditionally they're not gonna leave
when you lose
your job or your bum or whatever and
they always hold it down
and they don't have sexual desires and
they're just some
angelic beings all right and then when
the red pill
in the matrix i think um when when the
red when he took the red pill it was
like you get to see life for what it was
you get to see life not in some weird
shady
thing but as it is you see reality
unfiltered
and the problem with that though not the
problem but
what stings is bro you got to have this
paradigm shift this thing romney talks
about called cognitive dissonance
when now everything you've been fed
growing up is a lie
and you see things for as it finally is
and bro it hurts i know has been through
it i've been through it romney's been
through it
we've all been through it as men and
women too but
at the end of the day the biggest lie
we've been told bro growing up
is about women and all the red pill
really you know taking the red pill just
shows you that women
aren't they're not bad they're not some
you know
demonic things just because they're not
angels but they're human beings just
like us bro
they're literally human beings just like
us
they have desires too they have physical
you know
intimacy and attractions too they
you know eat and poop just like us
they're not to be something that's
pedestalized bro yeah you got girls with
only fans you got guys out here
paying hundred dollars a month for
pictures bro like that
bro we're not even gonna get into that
soy boys
i saw this one post where this person
was like only fans
is like a small business and like if you
if you watch only fans it's like
supporting your local small business
instead of supporting like the big
companies i was like damn that's damn
that's sad bro
i saw this post on this girl who who had
like he was big on only fans right
and obviously do your thing i don't i'm
not i'm not gonna say anything but
at the end of the day cool you know
girls are living in recruit difficulty
and
you know it is what it is but for those
of you that don't understand the call of
duty reference this girl
would take baths right i think it was
showers or bats
and what she would do is she would sell
her bath water on only fans oh my gosh
and
some listen listen listen guys some simp
every
saturday like clockwork would literally
pay
thousands of dollars for like that week
that batch
of bath water and then until next time
she showers
and it's like bro what yeah
really out here doing that it blows my
mind so
islam the red pill guys it doesn't make
it doesn't make us
hate women or anything like that it just
makes us see them for what they are
and kind of just navigate life
with them by our side not navigate life
with them as the goal
there's nothing wrong with living a life
pursuing women as your goal if that's
what you want to do just know it's not
going to be fulfilling
it's extremely high investment
low reward or low yield and bro most of
the time you're probably going to get
clucked as anh says
so i don't know if that's some life you
guys want to live whereas if you chase
the purpose if you chase
you know living leaving the world better
than where you found it
it's never going to be something where
you regret anything it's never going to
leave you
like a woman and it's not a problem like
that that gets into the whole thing
about like
let me let me finish my point real quick
one has his purpose it's nothing wrong
about
women you know and then everything right
about men
all i'm saying is women are still people
and people leave at the end of the day
we are going what are you saying this
guy
i said that it stems back to like dudes
having to be about their purpose and
women
[Music]
having to be about their purpose which
is different than what a man's purpose
would be
i want you what you mean on that because
a lot of people might be like what is
this guy talking about
well see as dudes we always
seek to accomplish a goal we seek to be
a part of that thing that's bigger than
us
and to leave something here like a
legacy or something or just do something
make some kind of change
it doesn't even have to be for us what
it could be for ourselves but we're
always striving to do something to
accomplish something that's
that's what purpose is for a dude and
for a woman
yes she can do that but that would not
necessarily be
her purpose her purpose would be
you know nurturing those relationships
that she has with those closest to her
whether it be family whether i be
friends whether that be her kids whether
that be her husband
you know like being creative and
let's say i don't know doing something
artistic
whether like creating something they're
using their creativity for some kind of
uh artistic pursuit like that but to see
a woman
try to do the same thing that a man is
doing it just that doesn't make sense
and that's what i'm referring to what
you're saying
is like all right
for the dudes the purpose thing
it goes right into it
you got yo i'ma tell you something that
all these women are saying
but can't a woman do everything a man
can do and better
no you're asking me if a woman could do
everything yeah i'm saying i'm saying
this is something i hear a lot from
women it's like
you got them chasing phds trying to
outwork when
uh out women outwork men and you got
modern radical feminism not even trying
to establish equality but establish
dominance over men
and they keep saying bro they're better
than us that they could do everything we
could do
what do you think about that i think
it's silly
because it's all right yes a woman can
do
what a man is doing but the question is
does she really want to if there was
nothing
no media program here there was no one
telling her
hey you should be doing this you
shouldn't let a man do this
and then you over here do this if if you
left a woman alone with no
influence no outside influence like what
would
internally she want to do and i
guarantee you
it's probably not going to be what a man
wants to do
because a woman will want to spend time
like let's say a woman is in a
relationship she has a man
she really really is into this dude
i she will want to spend time with this
dude and she will want to
talk about the relationship that they
have together she'll want to
uh increase what they have together like
she'll try to make the relationship
better she'll try to have a better
connection
with her dude in whatever sense
i but a dude yeah he'll do that but he's
more inclined to
[Music]
oh actually i i want to go to the gym
and get this workout in
i want i want to accomplish this goal
over here so that i can make x amount of
money
um for myself like i'm doing martial
arts like
or i'd rather be in the gym training
right now than sitting here on the sofa
watching netflix with my girl
i don't have a girl but i'm saying from
past experience when i
did have uh a girlfriend whether it was
the first one or the fiance that i had
bro like we'd be sitting on the sofa
watching netflix and i'd be asking
myself man what the hell am i doing on
this sofa you know from experience bro i
agree man like
at after that week that you're talking
about yo women feel charged up they feel
ready they feel fulfilled they're like
oh my god i want more time
after that you're just here like
what did i just do for all this time man
like i could have been doing this
there's nothing wrong with taking time
to decharge
and not decide to recharge and de-stress
but
as men you're right man like that's not
our main thing
yeah i feel like from personal
experience
when i was on my purpose
and the person was changing for me
and it was mainly islamically changing
for me things were good
from what i could tell but as soon as i
started to try and change for the person
and i kind of regressed as a person
it literally went to hell and it just
got worse and worse progressively so
it's kind of like from my experience
even if you were to argue that no the
vice verse of what we've been saying is
true
actually from my experience personally
does not work for the relationship
actually spirals heavily downward
you my friend are on something right now
you're right
um people are out here like and by the
way women want to admit this
you guys already know this woman will
take this to the grave no it's okay babe
don't don't go to the gym
you know you don't have to work out for
me you know you can become i like dad
bots that bots are in
that's the biggest lie you've been
that's the biggest blue pill i've been
told
um you know you could you could be home
you could just spend time with me don't
leave don't don't do this don't do that
bro listen to what a woman says and just
see how far you go with women
but go with what women act and behave
like and go with that
and then see how far you go dude that
should be with everyone
but again it's it's definitely most
important with women
because hey women will say one thing and
they'll do another
yeah you actually remind me i was uh one
of my co-workers my old co-workers he
was driving me home
and you know he's a guy who works a lot
he used to be really really big
and i asked him like okay how are you
working out nowadays and this and that
and he said because we work
like a very physical job so he said like
this job is my workout now
and then he said you know i actually
wanted to
lose some of this muscle and be just a
little less lean
or a little less built and i asked why
and he said other than him doing it for
himself he mentioned that his girl
actually prefers him that way and i was
like
um sometimes a girl will
kind of test you like say something like
you should get a haircut or you should
do this or you should lose some weight
or you should
this that the other just to see if you
will actually listen to her
get out of your frame and change for her
and if you do that
then your value decreases in her eyes
because it's kind of like
he's not that man right he's listening
to
what i'm saying and eventually for most
women that just gets old they don't want
i was actually um abu american he posted
a video
of this uh blonde lady i think she's a
celebrity on a talk show
and she was talking about how her man
kind of commanded her in a way
and she loved that like i've seen that
you've seen that right yeah yeah like
she's a big drama queen she runs up the
house
out the house drives down the street
she's angry and when she goes back he's
like listen i care about you and stuff
but you can't do that i respect myself
too much i'm not going to be with you if
you do that okay
next time yeah next time she stops at
the door then he slowly slowly said now
you can't even leave the room when
you're mad at me
yeah you can sit there in silence but
you you can't even leave the room
and she loved that she loved that but
most women on the surface
probably including her before the
relationship would say if he does that
to me
he's out this thought it's kind of like
he's controlling he's this bro
society places you know society calls
things controlling
as when a guy really wants to put his
relationship first
and make it work it's not controlling
yeah there's things you could do that
are controlling like don't
put an ankle monitor on her and give her
a curfew i'm saying that but
more times than not there's no there's
nothing really you know controlling
about a woman if you're being honest and
it's not coming out of insecurity
it's generally coming out of you looking
for the best of your relationship
so i agree with that and and to to kind
of address
on um rami's point about
this this whole thing with women testing
us bro they don't wake up every day
like some demonic beings and they're
like oh how do i ruin my you know
marriage or something like that nah they
don't they don't do that bro they
they're subconsciously doing that and
it's because we live in a world
just abundant in soy boys like you
mentioned
they're just they're out here by the by
the dozen a dime a dozen
and there's no real men out here anymore
so what do women have to do they now
have to have this like
constant sub subconscious screening
process to be like okay cool
because my man still got it cool he got
it all right cool
literally the next day cool let me let
me say some dumb ish
you know and then see what it see if we
can we can shake him out
just because like they need to
constantly know bro we live in a world
where men just don't have values and
integrity anymore
they're always changing they want daddy
bro they want daddy bro
and at the end of the day they're not
gonna like you're not gonna be
daddy being who she says she wants
but you're also not gonna be be be that
being what society wants you to be you
gotta go you gotta live life you gotta
get experience out here
now i'm not gonna go get experience and
you know do this do that i'm just saying
like at the end of the day
experience and wisdom is way better than
useful
useless you know propaganda knowledge
from
society yeah dude let me let me take the
ball here bro you're being a ball hog
uh romney let me tell you this story bro
so
when i was with my ex i'm talking about
the first girl that i was with man
she was brazilian we were in high school
and i remember i was growing my hair bro
i was getting dreads
and like as i was growing it up bro you
got to go through like that awkward
stage
you know and like as i was going through
the awkward stage she was like oh your
hair looks ugly
you should cut it and i was like yeah
you won't be saying that soon
and bro she just kept trying me kept
testing me like oh you should cut your
hair like please cut your hair please
like do it for me do it for me
and i was like nah nah nah and i
remember my friends were like asking
like oh why are you
why are you growing your hair i was like
i'm getting dressed and they asked me
like oh what does your girl think about
that i was like bro it doesn't matter
what she thinks i'm gonna get the dreads
either way
yo and when she saw that she was so mad
at me
but it's like she respected the fact
that i was about mine
and i wasn't buckling for yeah
whatever she was saying bro but then
fast forward
right fast forward like a year after
we had gotten back together and i
started growing my hair out again i was
like i'm gonna do a bun
i'm gonna do this man bun thing and as i
was growing it out she kept testing me
like oh you should cut yeah you should
cut here you know what i did bro
cut my hair i cut my hair oh my god and
i remember
i was in the house with her mom and she
was coming downstairs looking at me just
like
shocked bro and i could feel it honestly
i could feel it like the amount of
respect that she had for me
and like the daddy status that i had had
just completely dropped
no she got you by the balls bro now look
at her eyes she
at that moment she's like yo i got this
guy i got him
i got in him i mean just just quick
quick reminder i got 10 minutes left but
we're gonna keep going
what time is it this is yeah and i got
to go to gym
right uh pretty pretty resourceful i
don't disagree with anything we talked
about today
i got i actually have a question for
both of you
i have a opinion on the matter but i
want to hear what y'all have to say
why is polygamy the right way
why is it something that should actually
be done why is it the natural way
for men and women i'm gonna go in on
this
rami you got anything to say i wanted to
i feel like this is an important point
because people
love to pick one or the other
why can't both be proper because
allah does not say only monogamy and
allah does not say only pelogeny
perhaps perhaps for some men polygyny is
better and that's just how it is and
that it is what it is
you can never say it's wrong especially
when you're dealing with subjective
morality
you can't prove it's wrong you can't but
at the same time maybe some men are just
fine with one woman maybe they can't
afford multiple maybe they are not
suitable
to be with multiple i mean they can't
take care of all of them mentally
emotionally physically financially
whatever other means so this whole idea
of why is this better or why is that
better
it's kind of dumb but the topic or the
question of why is polygamy okay
i would flip it and say why is it not
okay can you bring anything objective
against it what's wrong with it
why is it unnatural for a man that's
what i would ask
all right so angel made this video
a couple months ago a couple years ago i
forgot on masculine
energy and feminine energy yeah and i
remember you
explicitly saying bro as men
we have masculine and feminine women
have masculine and feminine the
difference is we don't have the same
amount
in measure so we have predominantly
masculine energy
and we have a little bit of feminine
energy women have a lot of feminine
energy they got a little bit of
masculine energy right
it's what makes us men and women
respectively but the problem is
as men the little bit of feminine energy
that we have feminine energy wants that
nurturing that care that that
almost that like attention and love and
it's like
the problem with men today is we're
getting it from the wrong sources don't
you guys agree
like men today are fulfilling that
little bit of like
feminine energy that needs to be
fulfilled and you know
fulfilled with something they're
fulfilling it with women
they're chasing women for that same
thing that women predominantly are
chasing us for
they're looking for that idealistic type
of love
not that real love i'm talking about the
idealistic type of fairy tale blue pill
hollywood type of love and they're out
here chasing a woman
and the problem with that is bro you're
chasing a woman
when women themselves don't even know
what they want women themselves might
want you today it might not feel you
tomorrow
and you're having all this expectation
on a woman which puts a lot of pressure
on women
let's not let's not lie about that too
and she's out here like yo i don't know
what to do with that
you feel me and it's like you want that
those those hugs and
and whatever and it's like bro at the
end of the day
that's not gonna give you fulfillment
and if it is it's only short term you're
fooling yourself you think it's gonna
you think it's gonna be forever and as
men
allah tells us plain and simple come to
me
you know we're detached and be connected
from god from allah
right we're going to women and we're
expressing our feminine side
venting you know gossiping talking about
people
and it's like bro what are you doing and
it's like you ever see a woman like at
the end of that like
they feel really good right because
they're predominantly feminine they feel
really relaxed at ease
like damn i got all my i can breathe now
you know like they come home from work
and they do that
as a man you don't feel that man like
you still feel like unfulfilled after
that but you go to allah
you replace that that you know you
fulfilling that
feminine side with a woman you you do
that with god oh man like
you talk you express your things you
repent
it's something else 100
i like that but answer the religion this
question
here's where i was going with that so
what i mean with all this
is imagine a man
pursuing a woman not having time
to pursue his purpose right why is he
pursuing a woman
more times than not he's pursuing a
woman because he's placed her value
which is right here next to him they're
the same and he's placed her over here
you know he thinks she's she's some like
top dog she's like the queen
you know and i gotta buy you know her
bath water every week and whatever
guys want to confuse themselves with so
they have this
this [ __ ] version of women in their
dome
compare that with a guy with four wives
he doesn't have this pedestalization of
a woman
he knows exactly what they bring to the
table he knows but definitely he has to
bring to the table
and at the end of the day he's not out
here idealistically pedestalizing women
he's not out here chasing women
his whole this whole thing of oh i need
to get a woman i need to get this i need
to get physical intimacy bro
he already has that he has four
different households and families
assuming you you maxed the quota of what
islam tells you
so you're not going to be out here
chasing women you're going to be chasing
your purpose
compare that with one guy who's only
been with one woman bro
he doesn't know anything else
he's gonna think that's all he can get
and he's gonna think that's all he had
there's no abundance in that
forget over abundance there's no even
subtle abundant mentality
he's only gonna think okay this is all i
have this is the only woman i've ever
been with
so this is the only woman that's gonna
love me therefore i gotta make
everything work even when she cheats on
me even when she does this
even when she doesn't you know she want
ghosts for a week
i gotta i gotta put up with it why
because it's still my girl
i only have this compare that with the
guy that has four bro
he's not gonna be out here sacrificing
his integrity and manhood for a woman
but at the end of the day it doesn't
make him better there's a lot of
prophets with multiple wives and there
were a lot of prophets with one wife
there were a lot of prophets with none
it doesn't make them wrong or right or
better than one another
it's just a way of life and i agree with
rami what's wrong with
having four wives there's nothing wrong
with it
you guys can easily see how there's only
benefit from it
if that's something you want to partake
in it
yeah just to add on to that point i want
to mention that a lot of the time more
often than not whether
people will admit it or not women i
don't want to say
um thrive off of jealousy because
obviously some jealousy is really bad
right like um the process that i sent
him said about a certain group of women
that they have something in their eye
and he was talking about this jealousy
that's really destructive
and i think ali already said jealousy
and i think like the uh like
huge amount of jealousy not a little bit
but he said jealousy from a woman
is from disbelief but the jealousy of a
man is from belief because
men are supposed to be the guardians of
women so if they're jealous
over something is because of that
overprotectiveness that even allah
put in us and commanded us to follow but
a lot of the time a lot of the time
women
don't want a man who is not wanted but
if they see all of a sudden
by a bunch of women she's going to be
she's just instinctively going to like
him so much more
just because he's popular that's why
celebrities even if they look like my
toe
get girls because they're just they're
they're they're you know
huge people they they have this huge
status they have money they have this
that
all these things that women
predominantly want so therefore they get
a lot of women
therefore they get even more women
because even if they don't get women
a woman may assume he does just because
he has those things
and that's competition yeah that
competition sometimes drives women
so it may actually a man of four wives
all the relationships
may actually have a better chance of
flourishing for that reason alone on top
of that now
you're adding to it you can't be with
all four of them at the same time
therefore you're going to be with one
and the other three may be missing you
and that's actually really healthy for a
relationship especially for a woman
so she has time to miss you and
fantasize and think that's that the
other
so when you do come it's that much
better because
generally you don't want to give a woman
all your quantity in terms of time in
terms of time
but you want to give her maximum quality
in terms of time even if it's a little
bit of time
and that is i would say the
not the golden rule you know what the
golden rule is but no no no
i'll call it this yeah the iron rule the
iron rule bro of
of manhood like at the end of the time
to address angel's
point polygenic is the only way the only
social
order that simultaneously fulfills a
man's biological imperative which is
spreading his seed
but the halal and rightful way and
simultaneously fulfilling a woman's
biological imperative which is to
literally get the best man that she can
get
with what she's been given right
simultaneously at the same time so
they're not out here doing one thing
sacrificing for the other or women
meeting theirs and men not meeting
theirs you feel me
he's doing both and i like rami's point
where he brought up
i burgered me at the end of the day
right that's all it is
but it's not something like it's not
something like oh islam just lets men do
whatever with
multiple people nah because then bro
threesomes and things will be okay and
permissible
in islam but they're not you're not
allowed to be with one of your wives
and be with the second one at the same
time no you know
there's there's levels to this it's it's
not something just do whatever
competition anxiety i ask any woman
watching this like do you guys
would you really want a man that no
other woman wants
answer that question now take that
answer
put in the put in the trash can because
that's the wrong answer now what do you
really want
it's it's not going to be nice oh i want
a guy that no other woman wants
nah bro you you might think you want
that that's what society probably
that's what mommy and daddy told you
growing up to go for that type of guy
that's not what you want though yeah yo
i want to give a quick observation i was
debating whether or not i should
mention this or not over the last few
days when i when i went live on tick
tock
i went from my dms being like dry for a
bit
to literally okay there is basically
some girls like something
in the tik tok live right
and everyone kept saying that like all
these girls are fighting over this guy
you know
whatever whatever and i'm not not it's
nothing about me right
it was my life but i'm not saying this
by myself my point in this is after the
live i literally got like three or four
dm's from girls
talking about marriage asking about
marriage
like what's good baby i'm in canada just
yeah literally i said anyone in america
like it's no i'm not going for that
anyone outside of canada anyone outside
of the area i can't but literally
just because there's one girl that
initiated something and then other girls
kind of jumped on it it became this
competition almost and
like whatever it's kind of something i'm
boasting about myself maybe it was
serious maybe it's not but i actually
got like three four maybe five dm from
girls just after that live
that night or the next day about
marriage literally asking about marriage
and it's kind of like you me personally
really quickly i'm gonna just catch the
next drama so we got like another hour
are you sure
yeah this is exactly all right meetings
it's already too late
dude i am not gonna stay another hour
bro cause i'm hungry
but continue i'm just saying like i got
myself an hour i thought you died
um yeah to end it off finally me
personally
i would never no matter what i would
never deny what did you call it on him
jealous anxiety or competitive
exaggeration anxiety
competition anxiety anxiety yeah i will
i will never deny that for the rest of
my life because of that
personal experience mm-hmm hundred
percent
women so great that it doesn't matter
let me just let me tell y'all what i
told my mom
all right because i was walking with her
and then i like brought it up to her
real casual i was like yo
i'm gonna have multiple wives and then
my mom looked at me like
are you stupid and i was like nah nah
i'm gonna have
four wives and then she's like you're
not gonna have four wives there's
no woman on earth that will do that and
then she basically asks for like the
explanation like why
why would that even work and how is that
even all right and i was like all right
so
we have a certain nature would you all
agree
like you have female nature you have
male nature
y'all would agree right
really quickly what do you say that like
chemically speaking i guess or
internally speaking you could say like
testosterone estrogen
kind of thing like we have males that
have method chemically speaking yes bro
100
you're right yes yeah so
what are you trying to ask for that
ronnie
go ahead and make that sip of ginger ale
real quick
there you go it's actually oh yeah it is
ginger ale all right
uh damn bro he knows you better than you
know yourself
all right well i mean enjoy the enjoy
the view but
um what i was saying is like you said
you said masculine energy
uh feminine energy that's what if i said
you said something very similar
it's kind of like what do you mean by
this it sounds like a lot of this like
new spiritual kind of you know gibberish
kind of stuff
so i was wondering like when you say
this do you mean like how men have more
testosterone
which makes them masculine and a little
bit they still have a little bit of
estrogen
while as for women they have a bit of
testosterone and a lot of estrogen
that's exactly how i refer to it in the
videos
oh okay so i refer to it in the
spiritual sense but i
i also referred to it in a more like
simplistic approach where
someone could understand it and just
grasp on to the the concepts a lot
better
all right but anyways anyway so i talked
to my mom i told her
i was like all right you have male
nature and you have
female nature female nature
is basically that of a woman is going to
look for the highest
value male now in terms of
what value is that is subjective between
whatever woman we're talking about for
one woman the value might be
that he's uh a professional basketball
player
for another woman the value might be
that he just makes her
feel loved and then for another woman
the value might be
that he's just very ambitious and he's a
go-getter he's always out there like
making money doing what he has to do
all right so in terms of what the value
is
it doesn't matter that's subjective but
what is objective is that
every woman will always seek the highest
value
male now for a male a male
nature is basically to spread a seat
to try to be with as many women as
possible and a lot of dudes
will try to say no that's not true um i
only want to be
with the girl that i'm with but dude
that is a lie because if you've ever
watched pornography
at some point in your life or if you've
ever looked at another woman in a
lustful way or in a way where you're
just like oh wow like this woman is
beautiful
dude like that is your male nature
beginning
to arise within you that is the thing
inside you that's
wanting you to go and reproduce
have sex with the woman to be able to
procreate and have
more of you many use that's the way
you know you you basically survive right
the woman if we were to think in
primitive times the woman would survive
by having
the male that could protect her the
highest value male
and then the male would survive by being
with as many women as he could find to
have as many kids as you could have
alright so that's that's male nature
that's female nature
all right with polygyny you have one guy
and let's say four women all right so
that's already taken care of male nature
because now he has four women
where he can have multiple kids let's
say he has four kids
with those four women that's 16 kids
that's a lot of kids y'all
that's a lot of kids all right but now
let's look at it from a woman's
perspective
all right is that or is that not taking
care of female nature
if there is now competition anxiety
present between all four women because
they're trying to get
as much time and as much love and
affection as possible from this guy from
this one guy
all right so for people that are
wondering
how is that taking care of female nature
bro
financially if that's what her high
value whatever she wants to have value
is
it is because financially he's able to
take care of four different households
attractiveness like physically of course
because science shows us through
pre-selection theory
um that women don't even find men
attractive because of who they are but
more so on how other women find them
attractive
so pre-selection-wise she already like
physically she's in
so we got financially physically if a
guy is physically and financially
the one most probably he has his life in
check and he has high integrity and high
man as a muslim men so that's in check
too
if she wants a religious or spiritual
man what else would a woman want them
think about it like most of the
biological necessities are met
so i agree it not only meets a woman's
requirements it exceeds multiple women's
requirements and what's crazy was crazy
romney before you chime in i see you i
see you
flying but i had told this to my mom
and like as soon as i finished she just
remained
quiet and all she could say is well i
would never do that i'm like ah
but you understand it though
you know it's not a lot um i'm actually
i'm glad you you said that before i said
well i want to say because it's directly
related
and i think this is a great closing
verse um
in the quran allah says you may love
something when it is bad for you and you
may hate something when it is good for
you
so allah is saying you might not like
something it might not sit well with you
emotionally because hating and loving
is just emotions right there's no logic
with it
so you might hate something but it's
actually good for you and you may love
something
but it's horrible for you so let's take
this example let's say monogamy for the
man
and the woman like i'm a specific man
specific woman or woman sorry in a
relationship
perhaps monogamy is not the best option
for them
they hate it but it would actually be
good for them
right and they the idea of polygyny to
them
may be something that they hate but it's
good
whereas monogamy is bad but they love it
they think it's good
and this can extend to anything in life
at the end of the day
yeah and a lot of women will try to be
like oh well
why can't it be the other way around why
can't it be
just polygamy in general like why can't
a woman have
multiple men like one woman and like
four husbands and it's just that's
going against your own nature and not in
the sense of like
okay i'm looking for the highest value
male even though
that kind of is because if you have the
highest value male you can't have
another one
you see what i'm saying if if you have
four guys
one of them has to be the highest value
male you can't have all four
of them that are the highest value male
1 like
they're all going to be competing
against each other to be the top
one to be the one that has you know that
is the highest value male but what i'm
trying to say here is that aside from
that
women want to have that connection
with their partner they want to have
something greater they want to have the
kids
and have that going and personally i
just feel like if a woman has multiple
partners
she's not letting herself have that full
connection
yeah it's just not i agree i agree man
like yo this this whole thing about
women women like here's the thing women
will say this
until they die why ca i could be with
multiple men i could
i could be out here with four or five
guys yeah you could be
seeing four or five guys at the same
time but you're still pursuing that one
that you know even though you have a
whole you know system like okay this guy
on monday this guy on tuesday this guy
wednesday
bro there's still that one that you love
and crave and pursue more than the other
and until you get that one it's almost
like you would do anything to get that
one
but that one doesn't want you as much as
the other ones why you feel me
so the problem here is women are
idealistically
projecting their own flaws and
shortcomings in their imperative
on hours see we don't think like that
bro if we had four wives we're not gonna
look at them be like okay which one's
better
and and look now bro we just want
variety we're not gonna care about okay
is this one better is that one better
not but women want that
but to address your point before rami
goes on and carries a torch
about women also want emotional intimacy
bro
the prophet salallahu sallam literally
taught us through the way of the sunnah
that you can't just be a guy out here
that's physically
getting into women you need to be
emotionally getting into them too
and emotional intelligence and moral
intelligence is something that
the prophet saws had i guess is the best
example of humanity
right we're not even going to get into
that right now but emotional
intelligence guys is
just as important as physical
intelligence with women
absolutely yes um
and just to touch on one of the points
you mentioned there even if a man
was not fair to each wife he doesn't
have the right to have multiple wives
because allah says if you cannot be fair
with all of them if you cannot treat
them equally then marry just one
so we're not even dealing with a a
potential
risk of men not being fair to all of
them because if he's a person who's not
going to be fair
he doesn't have the right islamically
and if he does then he's going against
the quran
which would be a sin um and now there
was a video i saw on youtube i forgot i
forgot what it was called
um but it had to do with pelogeny and
it's an islamic video
um and it basically gave some some point
so
we all hear the the normal statistic of
there are more women in the world than
men
especially in very specific countries
where the women almost like
double the amount of men and like insane
things um
he also mentioned that there were
studies conducted there were studies
done that showed that women with
multiple partners actually have
more problems with like intoxicants and
uh addictives and all of that bro and
mental health as a whole
yes mental health thank you um and it's
kind of like
again you may hate it when it's good for
you you may love it when it is bad for
you
and you may think that you want to be
with multiple men but perhaps
that will be the thing that causes the
drinking problem that you have or causes
mental illnesses and i suggest you go
you guys go find that video it's um it's
basically a white background and like
this cartoonish guy
talking like it looks realistic but it's
also a drawing if you guys want to look
it up as with palligenie in islam
but um yeah he had i think 10 points but
a lot
um this stuff isn't really uncredited or
unfounded even in secular means
bro as as muslims we need to be the top
1 men i agree 100
this is just a psa to everyone like
most women today have daddy issues so if
they meet a guy out here that's
physically everything they want
but emotionally not she's not gonna be
fully fulfilled she's still gonna have
that guy on the side
and forgot if a woman meets a girl that
a woman meets a guy that's
emotionally everything she wants vents
to him
does everything cool he's always there
but she's not physically attracted to
him he doesn't have that energy
she's not going to be all in bro if a
woman meets a guy though that
literally checks every single box and
knocks it out of the park
yo there's nothing else there's nothing
you can't do
yeah you literally come back right as i
know it says
yeah exactly exactly it's daddy bro
women want daddy
and i'm sorry but you can't have more
than one daddy
you could have a dad and a step dad but
it's like
whoever the real daddy is i'm not
talking about uh
is it i'm not talking about biological
right like you could have a step that
you have a real dad but like the stepdad
treats the daughter more like daddy than
the real dad
so it's like the daughter is gonna give
the
dad more attention then she's gonna give
the real dad because that's
daddy bro and it's weird me putting it
in that
in that example but that's exactly how
it is when women grow up they are
looking for
daddy bro and daddy is different for
every single woman
and like you said bro you a girl could
be talking to five
six seven guys but there's gonna be that
one
guy who doesn't give her that much
attention
but when he when he's with her she feels
like
she's on a whole nother planet and she
will literally drop whatever she's doing
to go hang out
with daddy she could bro she could be
about to go on a date with this one guy
but then
daddy hits her up and says hey what you
doing i'm free for the next hour she
will drop what she's doing with this guy
to go hang out with daddy there's this
there's this phrase um
women women break rules for daddy but
create rules for simps sure
yeah so when you say there's this
checklist and like a guy has to check
all the boxes the woman has
do you mean a conscious list that she
makes in her head or she writes on a
paper
or how exactly would you say that works
subconscious bro subconscious this is
home to her
guys this is female psychology 101 a
woman growing up
will have these things that make her
feel home make her feel safe
oftentimes though where men f up is this
whole thing that makes her feel safe
could overtly be danger could be not
safety
could be unpredictability or instability
because that's all she had growing up
so think of it like this look at a
woman's upbringing look at what she
always wanted
if she's from a place where she never
had stability never wanted this she's
not gonna want a guy that's always this
always predictable always doing
everything right
always texting always you know giving
her flowers now she's not gonna want
that
a woman who's had that growing up will
appreciate that and want that
but even then to some extent no that's
i got to chime in but i'm going to let
you finish i'm going to let you finish
i'm going to let you figure it out okay
so
bro so rami think about it like this man
the only way that you can be daddy
is if you are not
in an imaginary world if you are not
blue pill
if you are not thinking of things uh
idealistically like you say
instead you are present and you are
seeing things for what they are you're
very realistic with what's happening
because
a woman will tell you what she wants a
woman will damn right
show you what she wants and like bro
daddy is going to be able to catch on to
everything
you know so like a woman may want you to
be
more assertive and more aggressive and
it's like if you have this
i don't know this crazy thing playing in
your head where she's your beautiful
little angel and you're over here giving
her flowers and giving her all your
attention
and treating her so nice bro she's
she's obviously going to be unattracted
to you because
she's throwing you all the signs she's
telling you what she wants but you're
not catching on to it because you have
this
idea of what it is that she wants but
realistically that's not what she wants
um yeah so we have to be emotionally
intelligent then right yes
bro you you got women literally here
creating arguments and scenarios
just to create turmoil just for that
emotional rollercoaster that the guy's
not giving them
just to see yo is he gonna is he gonna
like stand his ground
is he gonna respect himself is he gonna
put himself first in the world
or is he gonna fold like he does every
single time that's why over time as
men slip the frequency of her creating
turmoil goes up
because she's like yo is this this guy
not have it do i have to do everything
here
but when a guy's out here doing teddy
things
and he's out here becoming the man and
being the man that she wants
bro she you're not going to have
arguments you're not going to fight
she's not going to create [ __ ]
out of thin air just to like just like
get some turmoil or get some
emotional you know polarity and all that
it's already there
yeah yeah it's cool it's cool all right
go ahead drink that ginger bro
why couldn't you manage right now i'm
just saying
but what i was gonna say
is that in reality bro if you really
think about it and you
you'll notice is more um you know
inshallah
hopefully you you do fill in those four
slots
hopefully we all fill in those four
slots you know inshallah i mean
but the more the more experience you
start having
with women the more you start seeing
that
these tests that fight is talking about
are very true
these steps that you were talking about
are trees tests that everyone's talking
about is very true
and at the end of the day bro you you
have maybe like
two to ten chances before the woman
completely loses let's say respect for
you instead of saying
she sees you as a beta she just loses
respect for you
once she loses respect for you bro it's
done you can't come back from it
two to ten bro some women can handle
more because they have more uh
attraction for you and they actually
want something more with you so they'll
give you
more chances to f up versus like
i'm pretty sure bro i'm pretty sure that
the uh what's it called
those dudes that are talking about game
they're talking about like
interest level where it's like a girl
might have like a level five
interest in you where it's like if you
mess up maybe you
twice maybe once like she just yeah
that's it it's a rap like she has no no
respect for you anymore
sees you as a she's a beta but if a
woman has like a level 10
interest level where it's like to you or
to her
you are perfect you know no one's
perfect but to her
you are perfect like the way you look
the way you speak the way you act
the way you walk everything just does it
100
for her and it's like she'll accept more
like she'll still test you bro
just like every other girl but if you
mess up
she'll she'll let it slide and then
she'll she'll test you again at some
point and then
she let it slide but i'm telling you two
to ten times
fax man like at the end of the day like
there's this survey done and it was like
women that are with men that they
perceive as like alpha males
when every now and then they do
something that's perceived
more beta more simpy more like
weak it actually increases her
attraction towards him
because she's like yo i'm not used to
that i'm not used to that soft side
conversely though women that are with a
simp
every now and then when he pulls
something that the kind of caliber of
he is wouldn't pull she's like what she
can't even take that seriously
like if a guy who's always letting
people walk all over him
finally stan stands his ground bro who's
gonna who's gonna respect that
but if a man who's always just holding
on never giving
every now and then he actually like
opens up to people people are gonna be
like okay cool this never happens don't
be like
let me appreciate this let me value this
yeah
and a lot of the time when these things
come up from women people people call it
even women themselves will call it toxic
they'll be like
me start me on my way to start a fight
for no reason uh call it toxic
i wouldn't call i would call it natural
maybe you shouldn't do it right but i
would call it natural
that a woman wants to do that what's
toxic is the way we've grown up
with this certain understanding of
relationships because it's so far off
from the truth
and intoxicates us in a sense that we
think as honestly idealistically
when it's not the reality and so that's
a more toxic
understanding relationships so it's not
tossed when one comes to bring problems
if that
satisfies her emotionally if you deal
with it the right way
it's toxic that you're not in a position
where
she she feels like i don't even need to
do that stuff that's that's a real
toxicity
yo i know i'm still hungry yeah dude i'm
actually really
drunk um i haven't had yet
i'm still fasting too bro let me let me
see you put some food in your mouth bro
nah bro you like that huh those dogs
chocolates are those those nuts
yeah the nuts i like nuts
yo but i me what i'm trying to get at
something bro i was trying to get it
something though you had to talk about
nuts if i had
lost the train of thought man why are
you why you had to mention the nuts bro
you know i'm
well you know i'm weak to nuts y'all
y'all know i'm on keto bro
i got nuts left and right center
all right yo so i think we should end it
there
uh all right should living in the day
you can't remember your thought
i can't bro then that's got to be he's
just he's just thinking about that's not
man like
oh my goodness he's got nuts bro
all right think of it just text me or
something what does that mean
is like enough or stop or something like
that like it's enough now okay
all right all right cool cool all right
with that being said
thank you my two brothers here for
joining on this episode of t3m and i'll
see you guys in the next one insha'allah